We are started when the team harron out.
To talk about alf much at the formula. And
yes i can remember him coming
years to come out quite
a lot because he had it different consignments
that he probably wanted to do. Prior
to others you know with the numbering they
knew what they were looking for. So he
used to have to come out quite
a lot. He was about my build about
five foot nine ten and didn't look
to have any fight on him or anything
else like that fairish hair and
a bit of colour in the cheeks
which was quite common for quite
a lot from england. No face
and. Pretty quiet sort of
a fellow military you know he did the job
very well. Several people inside reckon
that he was he was very careful when he
gave instructions. As far as making sure
that people got the right message. Yeah
well he was there and that's what i was
going to say
a while ago about the the accuracy
with which they had to do i
had to take some to make the temperance
i think out of redwood and they had
a big assembly area where
they used to assemble
a whole member up above and we used to have
to sling the stuff down there and send
it up and i got up there once and i was off
siding we were slack outside there and
i was i siding with this little template
mark. I think may have been his title. And
i had the steel type.
Major in and he said that
near enough is not good enough if
the type bisected certain area is
not good enough he said near in this
business near enough is not good enough. And
when you realize just
how important that is
a small little deviation on the width of
a mark. I will finish up first out by the
time i get to the other end of the plate
you know and that impressed me very much.
When i felt that you know i was very
careful. I was while holding
a tape for now i'm words do you ever
remember them putting the tapes out in the
harbor to get the temperature down. You
know going to remember that that happened.
Yes apparently it did happen. Over
apparently when the when the temperature got
very hot the tapes would stretch too
far and they put them up against
a standard which was apparently wood which
we didn't expand so much. And if it was
measured somewhere i don't know what it
was on the wharf or what it was inside
a where there was
a permanent measure there. And they and
they used to compare them periodically on
a hot day particularly and the stories.
Anyway i don't know how accurate they are
of them giving the but the tapes
a swim as they call to
get the girl down is
a beaut as i say then it would be necessary
after you know what this little fella
told me you know in the bandy legged
fellow i can't remember his name. I wasn't
with him that long journey of the
other doormen long people. Well.
No no not particularly those of the ones
that i was more immediately concerned
with you know that i did mention. Did you
see it. Well at all. He was in charge of
verse dealer action. And i don't want
him. No one's come to mind but i
was on the construction
a fellow name you or he was on it mostly
on this side. I think in my i had
a counterpart on the southern
side i don't know but he was
a stocky but i get their press that he was
an american but i'm not sure he may have
been be was
a scot. I think. But you know it whether
he worked in america. I don't know and i
think this was it was
a scot but he'd worked in america. Yeah you
know well he came down to the wharf on
occasions and because the right time that
we unloaded all those cables. It was
probably the best job after going to work
an all nighter and union rules where the
two of his had to accompany us so that
meant that there were four men for diamond
beach lad came out with one of those
coils particularly if they had
a big drag from under the combs in the
hatches it take about twenty minutes because
the queen had to go in hell. I love gear
and as they came out we guided them down
to where they had to be
stacked each of us grabbed
a hook to let go and went back by the fire
for the rest aright. So we've got pretty
good money and i was pretty good. I got
the biggest pay i think i ever got down
there was fourteen pound and i don't know
how many ships were tied up and let go
and how many all nighters. We did now. Do
you ever hear anything or see anything of
them dumping steel in the harbor
overnight. No i didn't i did. Again i got
a story you know of them dumping badly
drilled plates. You know didn't hear or see
anything of that. The only thing as
far as i was concerned i used to have
a big hopper with. Rings
on each corner and
i cry and used to pick up the shavings
they'd use and swing them out and dump them
on
a barge or punt and i
know that there was great
stress laid on not spilling but it
fails dumping i didn't say you know.
I probably went back to newcastle. I don't
know where i went really but. You know
it was
a lot of them as you can imagine from all
those drills. I can remember there was
a scot for all and i care he had two sons
the both worked and i was one of the
first suggest
a whale the timing's out in the world about
what was this do you member the sons
names. You know but i go. Well
as an alfred kerr who was
a driller yeah well no i'm. Yeah well
i could have been one of them. I was
back scott. You know all very black hair
and everything else like that but dark
complexioned i tell me the different parts
of scotland where they are like that.
And another family. There was smith. With
a little fat fell on them and start
w out here. He had two sons and
one of them was now a mass. I'm
a double team and i can't remember the
other one. But one of them played football
with us. If i think it
a way that was the reason james beer
came over to your end was that he was in
charge of substructure and for the whole
bridge job you see he was his were he was
a concrete and stone man he was in charge
of the quarry as well. Yeah you know and
but he and hit well who was still in
charge of steeler action. They had an
arrangement and went before the arch joined
that one would be in charge of one side
for the whole lot and the other one would
be in charge of the other you'll see. But
when they joined then after that then he
would revert to being in charge of all the
substructure. Yes i remember the name
hopeful when you mentioned it but i'm no.
Association really that i could
point to with him. And now
i wonder i wanted to ask you in your travels
and interviews or anything else like
that. Have you ever heard the name of siddle
oh i've heard it mentioned but not not
much no lie. Visited earlier to you by
the way is name identity still alive
actually but his name is on one of the
lists and i look it up for you. Said no
one made see was
a fellow to tell me i talked to selling
to be over twenty one you know and
a hell of
a good athlete and i bumped him during the
war. We're both in the table and he was
a captain then said was pretty bright and
he started out there with us. But he was
finished up with as italic like and he did
a lot of work in the office that was in
between the two buildings. That's was
a main office and drawing office doing it.
Yes that's why i said finished up. You
know i just wondered you know is a bit of
a scallywag too that i won't go into that
you might save me. If he's around but he
was a very good tweak
alone and you know and
a good mate to me. Well i'll the feeling
you feel i have just look at me. Book just
hold on
a minute. I let looks as if the low we
have on the list is not him it's somebody
else's search was george low so it must
be him. Can you remember anyone else down
there. Well i think i've gone through most
of the names i did write some down and
i was going to tell you about that. That
jordy fellow but i thought of that. We
were on the wharf. But idle at the moment
and right across towards mcmahon's point
there were two fellows on the boat rowing
boat that looked like and they were
pulling in pulling in pulling in and i had
a pile right on the back so that the bear
was sticking up in the air and i said i.
Geordi what do you reckon they're doing.
He says they're pull it out can't just
keep water going down. I don't. That
was priceless you know as quick as
a flash is when it was supposed phenomenal
no i didn't even know what i was going
to say. And that was the little geordi
that felt i described earlier being jockey
size you know and that i just had to tell
you that because i told it 100 times you
know in my lifetime and there
was big bill brown he was
a geordi he worked out there is in that
photo that i gave john andrew and his
son came down to visiting one day
a big six foot strapping bloke and we
mentioned about it and both as i. He said
that he cried for the first six months and
he said use that used to sleep with us.
We are as you know in at all but
there will be had. I try and talk
a bit like him and he said. One night
we in used to get sleepy sense and one night
he fell out of bed and he said we had
a good sleep. It's if you book it if i don't
know no other pushed him out long ago
. So that was billy brown just
a couple i think that i think that they
do you know how many of them were brought
out by doing one long or.
You know there was quite
a lot of georgism middlesbrough fellows
there i do you know how many were brought
out and how many just sort of came you
know i don't know. Numbers. I didn't get
that you know information in in my experience
there. But i understood and because i
was pretty young and silly according to
said i understood that most of them were
brought out you know most of the palms
and we called them time and that they
were from door milan gorman long's employment
they were there and we thought that
they were sent out and specialists. Yes
well the key ones were i know that i was
about twenty but that's including mr.
Innis i don't think there was any more
than that. Did you ever come across any of
any of the people that worked on the arch
i mean for instance if i went on that i
mean it was jack harris
for instance he was
a house taffy taffy they used to call him
you. He was a boss rigger i think yes
a little fellow they reckon he was like
a spy. They could climb all over the place
you know he used to be like to be known
as the human fly. That's right. That would
be the same fellow and i think he was
a welshman was you know i think
they nickname was taffy. Yes the
little fellow as they were he was one of
the ones that were brought out so i was
alf but it but i don't think there was
more than twenty that i can actually trace
that. I made
a lot of the others came out under under
regulation schemes and such like you know
. You know. And some paid
their own way. I was
part immigration and part something else
and someone got sponsored yeah yeah. A
kiddie young kid came down there one day
with jock's lunch and he's at the gate and
a fellow said jock who. And
if you said he didn't know
a surname. So the fellow saying out how
a shark and i went about twenty of
them stood up because there's quite
a few scots there too but
that was just another side
a cloud side belfast dualities yeah. Oh
yes but you meant getting put off and
when that one. You don't remember the
actual time i remember the occasion because
i've been warned. You know things were
pretty bad outside. And i'd also been warned
that i'd be one of the first because i was
one of the last ones to be put in that
particular section. And with the.
Stopping of the steel coming out i was
there done that. So that's it. I know i
mean they had to start looking put thing
else and it was pretty hard to define
a thing or we got we on the dole. And
i when i went onto the dole. But.
I remember what it was that oh well it
was only on the coupons in those days i
can't remember the actual money but it
was very difficult to get the ingredient
that you want because
the government put out
a table and you motor the dealers would
give you what was on that table. I
wouldn't deviate at all. We had
to have to go up to me and it is
a hall at north sydney to pick it up and
when i moved that i used to walk from lane
cove. I mean these are home and
then i got will leave work two in
five i had to do two days or two
weeks two weeks in five weeks. I
think it was three penta then
we have any sixteen shillings
a day you were married then
used to till we got to we
were living with my wife people quite
a while and then at always turns
out we moved on into college and
that's what we paid $16 sixteen shillings
a week when we could pay and
what about when you couldn't.
Well i think the firm's name was
hardy and gorman and mr jones
was the agent the jester correct our
collective end because in between. I had
a couple of other jobs. And i worked
in the gas company for a while as
a labor and then i applied for
the buses and it took eighteen
months to go through and when i was called
up eventually. There were fifty two of
its went in the deal ever passed.
So i got
a start and we want to move today why so.
We were always very honest and i told mr.
Jones and i don't remember the
amount we were behind in meant
but they gave but
a clear bill to move out and i'm
sure that was the end gorman.
And so we moved down to day. Y
and i started on the buses. What
from the depot down it brooke. Was it
you know i know that was it. Actually i
started to burwood depot. I used to
have to hit. From nine cove to berlin
and that was for five months and then i
got to kelso road. Martin and then from
mosman i went to man any where the old
train depot us and from there i went to
book my friends up where you're
a conductor or driver. I was
a conductor for about eighteen
months and then i was
a driver for the rest of the time you
won't be getting your first training as
a conductor when you first started.
Yes very much very very you know.
Well very interesting
situations occurred quite
a time you do your three days with the
king. Yes yes i'm sure we did that. Yeah.
Three days and that. That's right.
Your second chord there and
. When i was learning the ropes. We were
told the conductor was in charge of the
people. Because i took buses in
preference to trams i stood down and
cost me eleven days saying you
know and i was working with
this fellow stand small
up for me would depend
and being in charge as i thought i when
the bell for him to go. We're waiting at
some place and he moved and i said
we're going right. You better go.
We just took
a chance and saying i'm entitled to this
but i'm telling you to go. He says i'm
driving it. And i'm stopping here. And
that was it the reason he was waiting was
for the pick to care. I think
it was you know i will bust him
a couple of times so i went so that was
my first experience in networks. You were
in charge of the passengers and he was
a jar to the basket. Yeah. Actually that's
what it was it's doing the driving idea
that you know what you
want. I found that i want
a driver with tact or you know man
that good job. You know so i was i was
twenty twenty seven years on the buses and
three and
a half years in there when we went in the
army during the second world war when did
you go in. Just after the japanese came
in. Well i think that was fully one of
forty to december. It's
a matter of fact i got on the phone to
go over and enlist the lieutenant cutler
received
a hero's welcome back to manly off the same
ferry i said to my wife jokingly i said
don't you know mob to say is or.
It was for lieutenant country
and where did you serve. I went to encamp
from the showground i went up to dubbo
down to bathurst. And then we went to the
middle east and i didn't see any action
in the middle east. We were
videos and where you were work
reinforcements and they were inclined to
look down on reinforcements because they
should have been in from the beginning as
i say. And we're in camp at news about
and then. Allow i mean took place while we
were there some some of the fellows went
up after i mean finished and the
next thing when you when you get
anything clean up and we want to queen
mary jane came home and then you go to new
kitty and i yeah yeah. After some leave.
I went to new guinea and we landed and
. I think milne may was the first one not
in action that that actually happened.
And from there we went to print chaffin
and there saddleback and i got
a bit crook. And then you know
i was sent back to hospital
in the lie and then back to mostly we are
involved in any action up there now i
find i'm missing gun in action. But i didn't
say i didn't see the enemy at all you
know i didn't like so angry i
enlisted because i thought i had to
the bombing. We were under bombing where
we were and then from places like that.
That's right and i'll i tell me my shot at
the shooting. Yeah you know i thought it
was
a nasty feeling you hear the pop and say
well east and then you could hear the sbt
. And i know the feeling
i was living there was
a child doing that or going to know all
about that. I always believe that this
evidence in the. England and you
got it worse than the soldiers
and i don't about that but the europe
certainly got it worse. I think yes yes oh
yes and when you got back. You were
invalided out where you were you know
i was given the option and i manpower.
Me out and i said do you want to be
manpower there. I got me after saying yes
or no and i said yes. So i was out and i
went back to the buses. I just beat
the band when i enlisted. Because i
stop the batsman from investing
just after i did and so i got
back. Oh i am money was made up my way
and just down the buzzer there for four.
Yes i was tired when i was twenty five.
Well it's still twenty four years
ago now. That was well i got my
time you know what chance. I got my
wife bought the band for me twenty
they didn't give and only there were
only i was on it but they both. And
after that. What do you do.
You stayed retired. I got
a job as a clerk with the
department of the army i call it
a quantitative depot now it's up
a term like that for metric
i believe but. Concord.
I sat down and i know george just
might set up with the army as
a clerk and i went from there to dimock
spilled eng still with the department army
inspection service they call themselves all
the fellas i think sam and all of these
things that the army uses their headquarters
and then they were transferred to come
. And when i turned sixty.
I'm tired. So you're
a member of the own workers union only
while you were on the bridge sure. And
they've been here. Yes i let it
go off and then when it be the am
a two year he hasn't the union.
But first an image and then
amalgamate it with a twin my you
know i was a deputy union rep for
a while and there and. I think they're
my way you know i'm straight and tramway
and matter i mean we're simply association.
Did you know pat reinhardt oh yeah pat
was pat was
a. It was the driver then there and
he took six from. When alan bagged on
died. I think. Did you know him alabama.
No. Well you know. Yes i knew pat. Yeah
very forceful type of bloke and amazing to
a fella. He died i think my heart
attack and as a well he collapsed at
a retired persons meeting i think yeah i
went to one of those well and billy white
but wiped out comment from that bio by so
i was anti-commie you know why i went to
be at him on. Yes it was called i did
a serious of tram and bus workers. Oh
yeah well bill bill. He worked a book in
a bar and we often had
heated arguments. Oh
we'll shake hands. You know so i like
that political motives were different say
because i was active in the
labour party down. But they why.
I was secretary for
a while and i was person you know i was
president of the federal and state in the
next councils mostly because nobody you
know to do them thing. Did you know. Well
bill white was active in the communist party
as well. Yeah. And he was active when
frank hardy stood against me and bill
wentworth for the seat of my kill i don't
because we couldn't get any money for
mars and let people know when our
candidate. I would say moved to
against you know ice and we poll
fairly well meant no way we were going
to win it. And i remember neck night and
the poll. Frank i was there and
bill went with no other candidate
and i wanted
a highly highly even something
amount. We reminded the
members and he read then all people
and not just one said people
getting in but i think you can. And
who ended up getting that seat and was it
really when you see wentworth yeah the
medevac prior to the actual
election. He was supposed to be
a terrible murder driver he was in trouble.
Tell three times and i didn't want this
damn thing you know i didn't want it anyway.
I ran to the labor party candidate. So
i said to myra my wife. I
just found out today that if
anything happened so went with who was
certainly the highest number of election i
said there will be ice. I said i have to
go live right through this damn thing
because i don't i don't you know. But anyway
he lived through and as you know he's
a pretty by play but he was he was one
piece of white smoke where you call an
antithesis or something like
that. He make and there was
a communist and when he met and
bill white they reckon it was
a capitalist. Yes of course. Oh
yes he did man he went with time
. But i used to send all our fellows
to him but you commonwealths as
they were in time about that was
a job. Did you get involved at all during
the period with the groups against the
communists. Yes yes
a matter fact. Do you know. The first
occasion was rent time too early
and it counted from now been stood
and i was his campaign manager.
And i didn't know anything about groups
they were how death but i didn't i was
a catholic but i wasn't practicing and i
wasn't satiated with any group at all
and i couldn't believe it. You know we
didn't want to coming into this and
that was when we were mainly napa and
these fellows were pointed out to me that
were active and then they know when
time stood the group trying to get it
and they nearly succeeded and i move the
amendment. He was going to be censured and
and move on. That's been something i feel
right now and i move the amendment that
was carried that he acted in good faith of
the big article in the hell that him and
the group tied together. Why the
fellers. I can't think we know
stills from any human associated with the
major he was one of the active members
today all in the labor party at the time.
What about kweli was here now quietly.
You know i know i was in the mine but he
was not and whom to mine teams don't like
him. He was in was
a delegate norton you know the president
of the union. Yes i interviewed him before
he died. Yes i had and i mean i
know mel in flight was to go into
a plane type of call this place to
go but did you ever hear the i gave
him a copy. Did you ever hear the
recordings that i did of him. He had
a lot on the union there including the
time when they. They were they were taking
the court ordered them to. To give up certain
amount of their funds they find them
and they were they were hiding their money
and we were involved in the union that
time i was i was a deputy union rep to
a fellow named stacy in brookvale but i
don't remember that particular part i know
that there was quite a few or
after alan bagnall died he was
a previous secretary.